لا تشتري السمكه في البحر فاهوال البحر هي
المتحكم
اما وهو معروض هنا في سوق الحراج المركزي
للاسماك في مدينه عدن فان اهوال الاسعار
هي المتحكمه عجز معظم باعه التجزئه عن
اقتناء الاسماك من سوق الجمله بعضهم خاطر
بذلك وهو يدرك واقعه تراجع القدره
الشرائيه للسكان نتيجه ارتفاع اسعارها
اسر كثيره في عدن تخلت عن وجبه السمك التي
كانت طبقا رئيسيا على مائدتها اليوميه لقد
تدهورت الاحوال اكثر فالاسعار اخذه في
الارتفاع وقيمه العمله المحليه انهارت
بنسبه 400 في المئه ورواتب الموظفين لم
تتغير منذ اكثر من عشر سنوات ناهيك عن
انعكاسات الحرب
خمسه بسته الباقه بالف
وخمسمائه الان بكم اظن
السلطات تعذر ارتفاع اسعار الاسماك لزياده
عمليات تصديرها الى دول الجوار فاتخذت
قرارات بمنع تصدير الاسماك وغيرت مسؤولين
في قياده هيئه المصائد السمكيه ناهيك على
انه هناك موجودين وكلاء موجودين وكلاء في
داخل مراكز الانزال ياخذ الاسماك بالكميه
بالجمله مما يسبب اعاقه توزيع الاسماك على
السوق المحلي يعني ما تحصلش الاسماك في
السوق المحلي وللاسف هذه الاسماك اللي
تروح ما تروحش للاسواق المحليه تروح الى
خارج المحافظه
لكن هذه الاجراءات ليست جديده وهكذا لا
يبدو ان جمله القرارات الاخيره تلقى
تفاعلا ايجابيا من الناس الذين يعتبرونها
كسابقاتها حبرا على ورق